(light music)
- I used to do a lot of
athletics in high school
but that was 10 years ago.
- I exercise a lot because I eat a lot
and so I exercise so I
can eat whatever I want.
- I am doing CrossFit about
five to six times a week
and weightlifting one time a week.
- I run about two miles once a week,
maybe twice a week.
- I don't think I'm quite
as fit as an FBI agent.
- I'm afraid of throwing up on camera.
- I'd like to pass but I'd
like to be top of the class.
I want to beat all these dudes.
- To attain a passing score
on the physical fitness test,
you must earn at least one
point in each four events
and at least a cumulative
score of 12 points.
Do we have to fight a
criminal while we do this too?
(exciting music)
- I think I was 30 for 30
and then the second half I slowed down.
so that sucked.
- I was trying to do a
sit-up a second but not quite
so I'm a failure.
- Puking might actually happen.
- I had good momentum up top
and then the last 20 seconds,
my stomach just wanted to eat.
(exciting music)
- Thought halfway through,
oh yeah, I'm just running and I was like,
oh, if this was a serious situation,
I better turn on the jets.
- My legs are on fire.
I was just imaging that he was a murderer.
- That was the fastest I've ever run.
Oh my God.
Can't believe I was five seconds off.
- Oh, I failed.
Fuck.
(exciting music)
- My goal was 60 and
after that I was like,
you met your goal, you're done.
- I got 40 which is respectable.
- Hung up on the failure.
Can't see the success.
- If I had longer limbs,
I'd be killing it right now.
(exciting music)
- My whole body hurts.
It's all fire and sweat.
- I stopped probably twice.
I started seeing stars
and I didn't want to push it so hard
that I might pass out.
- I got 11 minutes and six seconds
which actually was faster than I expected
because I was kind of gassed
out at the end of this.
- I came in at 13:10 which disqualifies me
because I got zero points.
- I'm really glad to
physically be able to get into FBI.
- I'm surprised that I
was able to pass the test.
- I got 13 points but I failed.
- I'm pretty stoked
that I was able to pass half of the test.
- I think I would take my
physical fitness more seriously.
I mean, this was fun.
I feel like I got a good workout.
- And I guess I'll continue
to not have a gym membership
because it seems like
it's working out for me.
- I'm going to start challenging myself
to set better goals and expectations,
meet and surpass those
so thanks FBI.
- I got to work on my cardio,
got to work on my speed.
I feel like I could get there.
- If anybody from the FBI is watching,
I've never done drugs
and I'm available to be hired.
(light music)